It's hauntingly beautiful.
Unborn Nevaeh Atkins reaches out of her mother's womb...
...and holds the finger of the doctor performing her C-section delivery.
He showed it to me and I was just like, "Oh my God, this is amazing."
Few lives will be as well documented as little Nevaeh's.
Her mother is a professional photographer, however, it was her dad Randy who snapped the pic.
Doctor called me over and said, "Hey, she's grabbing my finger."
So I just ran over there and just grabbed the shot...
...and I was just in awe looking at it, it was such an amazing picture.
I heard you were nervous that you were gonna miss it.
Very nervous.
Alicia gave her doctor a canvas print of the photo.
The doctor knew it was an amazing photo right away.
The next day, that's all he could talk about for weeks.
And after a thousand likes on Facebook, she's even gotten a few offers to buy the picture.
A couple of them has said that they would love to have the photo for their organization...
...for when they're against abortion.